قال وزير الخارجيه لبريطانيين جيمز كليفر
لان مركزه ثقه جيو سياسيه بدا ينتقل صوب
الجنوب والشرق ان الحصه الاكبر من
الاقتصاد العالمي ستتمركز بين ايدي دول في
امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا واسيا واضاف
الوزير في خطاب عن ملامح السياسه الخارجيه
لبريطانيا في العقود المقبله ان على لندن
ان تتبنى اسلوب الاقناع في التعامل مع تلك
الدول
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي اسباب مغزى
توقيت اعلان بريطانيا على لسانه وزير
الخارجتها عن الاتجاه في علاقاتها نحو
الجنوب والشرق والكسب دعم المزيد من الدول
بالديلوماسيه الصبوره والعلاقات ذات
المنفعه المتبادله واي رابط لذلك مع
مجريات وتداعيات النساء بين الغرب وروسيا
ما هي المنافع والمصالح مع الدول المقصوده
في التصريحات وهل ستكون على حساب مبادئ
اساسيه ترتكز عليها بريطانيا من قبيل حقوق
الانسان مثلا كيف سيستقبل الجنوب والشرق
الرسائل الى البريطانيه الجديده بالنظر
الى خارطه التحالفات الاقليميه الدوله
[موسيقى]
لندن تقلب خيارتها الدبلوماسيه وترى ان
عليها ان تسلك دروبا جديده توصلها الى
الشرق والجنوب حيث دول يوصف بعضها بغير
الديمقراطي والذي لا يحترم حقوق الانسان
هدف قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كليفر انه يحتاج الى تعديل في صوره
المملكه المتحده وفي طريقتها في تدبير
مصالحها الاستراتيجيه الى الحد الذي اثار
السؤال بشان علاقه المبادئ بالمصالح في كل
ذلك بريطانيا تفصح عن الخطوط العريضه
لتوجهها الجديد في وقت لم تضع في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا اوزانها وبالتزامن مع
توجه عشرات الزعماء الافارقه الى واشنطن
للمشاركه في قمه امريكيه
فهل هو زمن لجرعه اعلى من البراكماتيه في
الدبلوماسيات الغربيه في سياقه مشابهه
مفتوحه مع روسيا والصين اذا توقف عند بعض
مما قاله وزير الخارجيه البريطاني عن
الملامح الجديده للدبلوماسيات البريطاني
مركز الثقه السياسيه تحرك باتجاه الجنوب
والشرق هو تحديدا ان هناك مئات الملايين
من الناس تمكنوا من تجاوز الفقر وهذا اروع
تطور حدث في حياتي وهو انتصار للنظام
العالمي والتجاره الحره والتنميه الدوليه
والابتكار والتقدم العلمي والان علينا
الاعتراف بان مستقبل بريطانيا لاحداث فارق
يعتمد على الاقناع وعلى كسب ودي نطاق
واسعا من هذه الدول
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من مدينه جلاستر
البريطانيه
الدبلوماسيه السابق وخبير في العلاقات
الدوليه ومن باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه
في باريس ابدا معك سيد ارثر سيد ارثر ما
عبر عنه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني انما هو
رؤيه دبلوماسيه مختلفه ما الذي املا هذا
التوجه في هذا الظرف
هنا هو ان بريطانيا تحاول ان تجد لنفسها
تجاهها جديدا بعد خروجها من الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي حصل خروج ست سنوات
عمده
حكم الحزب المحافظ كان هناك كلام حول ما
يسمى ببريطانيا العالميه وكانت هذه الفكره
كانت نظريه يفترى ان تقول بان بريطانيا
خارج القاره الاوروبيه هذه هي الفكره ولكن
الصعوبه والتحدي والتحقيق ذلك فعليا لانه
في الواقع بريطانيا ما تزال تعتمد اعتمادا
كاملا على اوروبا من ناحيه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والامنيه وبالتالي فهذه حاله
دراسيه
لحكومه فاشله تحاول ان تؤسس لنفسها حك
سياسه خارجيه جديد جديده وتفشل في ذلك
يعني بغض النظر عن امكانيه نجاح هذا
المسار من عدمه وقد نعود اليه في سياق هذه
الحلقه ولكن عندما تكون هذه الرؤيه
الجديده مبنيه على مراجعه من لجنه
السياسات الاستراتيجيه اي دلالات يحمل ذلك
يعني انا اتفق مع ضيفكم من انجلترا في ان
البركزيت او الخروج البريطاني من الاتحاد
الاوروبي املا على لندن تحديات جديده لانه
حتى الان يبدو مسارا اقتصاديا فاشلا اذ ان
الاتكال ما زال كبير عن القاره الاوروبيه
كما ان التقارب الذي كان يعول عليه مع
واشنطن بما يمكن ان يعوض عن التراجع في
العلاقات مع اوروبا لم يكتمل لاسباب عديده
ترتبط ايضا بما حصل في السنوات الاخيره
همم بعد رائحه كورونا وبعدها اعاده النظر
الامريكيه مع بايدو اولويات الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي بريطانيا اليوم لديها
محاوله لان تفعل اوتران ديكلوماسيه جديده
هي كانت ضمن الكومنولث تتعامل مع
مستعمراتها السابقه على اساس التبادل
الاقتصادي او على اساس بعض الامتيازات لكن
ذلك طبعا غير كافيه كما ان همم دول
افريقيا وعدد من دول امريكا الجنوبيه
واسيا التي مازالت تنظر الى العواصم
الاوروبيه بوصفها المستعمره السابقه او
المستغله السابقه للثروات يريد الوزير
الانجليزي الان ان يقول ان لندن تراجع
سياساتها تجاهها وان عدد سكان هذه القارات
الاسيويه والافريقيه والامريكيه الجنوبيه
يساوي اكثريه سكان الارض فبالتالي من
الضروري العمل مع بلدانها ومن الضروري
اعاده النظر بطريقه العمل البريطاني او
الانجليزي السابق لكن هذا الكلام
تتحدثون عن اعاده العمل بدبلوماسيه مختلفه
ما المقصود بذلك كيف يمكن ان تقارب
بريطانيا هذه الدول قبل ما نتحدث عن
التوجه ان كان بريطانيا خالصا ام هو توجه
غربي بشكل عام
يعني طبعا اعتقد انه توجه غربي بشكل عام
لكن فيما يخص سؤال حضرتك اعاده النظر هي
من خلال التركيز على التبادل التجاري مع
هذه الدول هي من خلال اتفاقات ثنائيه
واحيانا اعاده نظر فيها ياكل قديمه هي في
تفعيل ما كان يسمى بمنظومه ويلز هي في
اظهار انا بريطانيا لم تعد موجوده فقط
لاستغلال ثروات الدول التي سيطرت عليها بل
تريد صفحه جديده معها وهي ايضا في التاكيد
على ان مركز القرار لا يمكن ان يستمر في
عدد من العواصم الغربيه بل عليه ان يصبح
اكثر رحابه في قبول اصوات برازيليه
نيجيريه من جنوب افريقيا من الهند من
اندونيسيا ومن غيرها انما هذا طبعا قد
يكون من باب الاستهلاك الاعلامي فقط مع
محاولات لاظهار
نيه توجه جديد من دون القدره على الذهاب
كذلك بعيدا لانه هناك اولويات ايضا
انجليزيه واوروبيه وامريكيه قد تتصادم مع
اولياء مع اولويات الدول التي ذكرها او
المناطق التي ذكرها الوزير الانجليزي
اجمعتم على توجهات داخليه املت او
التزامات داخليه املت هذا التوجه لكن ماذا
عن العوامل الخارجيه ترى ما الذي سرع في
وتيره هذا التغيير في الرؤيه البريطانيه
وهو الذي افصح عنه في اوقات صادقه وزير
الخارجيه ليبدو ملحا اكثر في هذه المرحله
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفر ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن مستعد لتدمير
القوانين التي تحمي الدول حول العالم على
حد تعبيره وان هدفه هو اعاده عقارب الساعه
للوراء حيث قوي له الحق هو حيث دول كثيره
تعاملت مع جيرانها على انها فريسه متابعه
ويلي
ما يثير القلق حتى هو انه مستعد لتدمير
القوانين التي تحمل الامم وكل شخص في
العالم بهدف بوتين هو اعاده عقارب الساعه
للوراء الى حقبه كان فيها القوي على حق
وكانت فيها دول كبيره تتعامل مع جيرانها
على انهم فرائس انه يشن حربا من امبرياليه
القرن التاسع عشر ويحط من النظام الدولي
والقيم عن قصد ومن خلاله هجومه على احد
اكبر منتج الحبوب والاسمده في العالم فهو
يتسبب في ارتفاع الاسعار ويكبد الفقراء في
العالم معاناه جديده
اعود اليك سيد ارثر سيد ارثر هل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا تداعيات او انعكاسات
على هذه الرؤيا التي تضعها بريطانيا اليوم
هل سرعت في انتاج هذه الرؤيه الجديده
للغاز وانظروا الى الدول اوروبا الشرقيه
التي الان مهدد من قبل عدوان العسكريه
روسيه عليها اذا في سياق المملكه المتحده
بشكل خاص اعتقد ان هناك محاوله
لتشديد والصلاه اتصالات اتصالات
ولكن ااا يعني وزير الخارجيه تحدث عن
الدول التي تحترم السياده بريطانيا وامن
بريطانيا وامن بريطانيا هو جزء من امن
اوروبا الا يعتبر ذلك كافيا سيد ارثر
وهو هنا يشير الى دول
خارج اوروبا
الاساسيه ولكن اعتقد ان هناك تحدي في ذلك
لانه في نهايه المطاف وفي الوقت الحالي
معظم التجاره البريطاني هي مع الدول
الاوروبيه
بالتالي
ليس من الواضح له ما هي الاسس الاقتصاديه
لهذه السياسه الجديده الملاحظه الاخيره
وتقدمها حول هذه السياسه هي ان الوزير هو
وزير جديد في وزاره الخارجيه وليس لديه
خلفيه وخبره في الشؤون الخارجيه
سواء سنتين قبل الانتخابات
القادمه التي متوقع ان يخسر حزبه فيها
وبالتالي فقط لا يكون لها موقفه وهذا
السياسي مهم جدا
اشار السيده ارثر بان تداعيات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا انما اظهرت هشاشه النظام
الاقتصادي
الاوروبي ما واجهت ما مدى واجهت الربط بين
هذه السياسه او التوجه الجديد لبريطانيا
وتداعيات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
لا شك ان هناك علاقه اساسيه بين تداعيات
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهذه
التصريحات هناك بالفعل شعور اوروبي عام
بان الارتباط في موسكو لجهه الغاز والطاقه
كان ارتباطا وثيقا وهو تعرض الان لخلل
يعرض اوروبا لتحديات كبيره في مجال
التدفئه والكهرباء والغاز وغيرها همم لكن
ايضا هناك شعور اوروبي وانجليزي بلا شكوى
امريكي ان الكثير من العواصم في افريقيا
واسيا وامريكا الجنوبيه همم لم تكن على
نفس حماس الدول الاوروبيه والدول الغربيه
عامه في ما يخص دعم اوكرانيا ذلك لان هناك
شعور بان الغرب تاريخيا وحاضرا يمارس
سياسه هيمنه وسياسه تسلط وهذا استفاد منه
بوتين لكي ينسى ان هناك امبرياليه روسيه
صاعد الان هي التي تعتدي في اوكرانيا وفي
سوريا وفي جورجيا وفي مناطق عديده وداخل
روسيا في الشيشان
وبالتالي هذا الموقف في دول كانت تسمى دول
العالم الثالث الذي يلوم الغرب على طريقه
وعلى سياسته الاقتصاديه الراهنه ادى الى
ااا يعني تمكين بوتين من الاستمرار في
حروبه لذلك من الضروري اعاده التموضع
واعاده البحث مع دول افريقيه واسيويه ومن
امريكا الجنوبيه
بمفاهيم جديده وبعلاقات جديده و بنظام
عالمي ربما جديد لا تكون فيه للعواصم الى
الدينا المطلقه لكن مره جديده هذه تصريحات
قد لا تكون قابله للتطبيق يعني نحن لا
نتحدث عن موضوع بريطاني فقط بل نتحدث عن
موضوع اعاده موضوع غريب حسب ما افهم من
كلامك
نعم هناك اسئله قد لا تؤدي الى اعاده
تموضع لكن هناك تساؤلات عديده حول جدول
استمرار بنفس السياسات السابقه بعد ان
اظهرت التطورات الميدانيه ان دوله كبرى
مثل روسيا بسبب سلاحها النووي تحديدا
وقدراتها ااا في الموارد الغاز والطاقه
وغيرها قادره على انزال خسائر اقتصاديه
كبيره وتهديد امن منظومه غربيه وبالتالي
هناك الان اعاده بحث في مسائل الدفاع في
مسائل الامن القومي اشكال التعاون وكيف
يمكن ايضا ان لا يسمح لروسيا بالتمدد في
مناطق
يشكو اهلها وحكامها رغم احيانا تناقض بين
الاهل والحكام يشكو من مادن استعماري غربي
كيف يمكن اعاده صياغه العلاقات الدوليه
على اساس جديد همم يكون فيه للديمقراطيه
مكان ولي الاقتصاديه السليمه مكان موازين
من دون ان تكون للغه السلاح والقوه التي
يستخدمها همم الرئيس الروسي الان الكلمه
الفصل في هذه العلاقات فهذه تحديات جديده
في الغرب وتعبير الوزير الانجليزي عنها
ولو كان ربما انتهازيا لاسباب سياسيه
داخليه لكنه يعكس اسئله غربيه مطروحه في
اكثر من دائره وفي اكثر من حكومه
يعني انطلاقا من ما ذكره الدكتور زياد
ماجد هل يدعم الغرب اوروبا الولايات
المتحده هل تدعم بريطانيا في توجهها هذا
وتتمي- وتتماشيان معها في هذه الرؤيه
الجديده
ان معظم الدول الاوروبيه غير مهتمه بالحد
الكبير بما تقوم به الحكومه الحاليه في
بريطانيا لانهم كما تعلمون هذه هذا هو
الثالث رئيس وزراء خلال سنه واحده
وباللاحده بمصداقيه كبيره هذه الحكومه لا
تعمل
انتخابات القادمه
انهو كليفر لليوم انما يصب في التوجه
الامريكيه ايضا هنالك قمه افريقيه امريكيه
ستعقد وبالتالي الا يعتبر ذلك استكمالا
للمسار الذي بداته بريطانيا منذ عام ان
كانت جونسون وزيرا للخارجيه
مع افريقيا
الى بريطانيا تقترح عليها هذه الفكره طبعا
كل الدول الافريقيه والدول الغربي والدول
امريكا الشماليه كلها تحافظ على علاقات
قويه بما يتجاوز الدول الحاليه فمثلا
سفارات امريكيه كبيره في كل افريقيا وايضا
مساء امريكا
امين
هذه السياسات
يبقى في وظيفتها الى اقل من سنتين
وبالتالي في الحقيقه لا نستطيع اهتماما
واهم
ليس فيها قاعده الذهبيه جيده
طيب ماذا عن حقوق الانسان عن الديمقراطيه
هل ستكون اولويه في سياسه هذه الدول انت
لم تتحدث فقط عن بريطانيا
هل ستعلي هذه القيم او تاخذ اهميتها هذه
القيم انها ام انها لم تعد مهمه بعد
تداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
لا انا يعني للاسف اعتقد ان مساله حقوق
الانسان والديمقراطيه هي الان في تراجع في
معايير العلاقات وفي تقييم العلاقات مع
الدول هناك طبعا احيانا عمل لراي عام لكتل
ضغط تحاول ان تبقي قضايا حقوق الانسان
وقضايا الديمقراطيه كمسائل شرطيه في
العلاقات مع حكومات لكن الاتراكماتيه
الغربيه وهمم
العلاقات الاقتصاديه والمنافع واداره
المصالح تتخطى موضوع الديمقراطيه وحقوق
الانسان نرى ذلك فيما يخص المنطقه العربيه
رايناه تاريخيا في ما يخص فلسطين نراه
فيما يخص دول افريقيه واسيويه همم نحن
باتجاه مرحله من العلاقات ستكون فيها
للمسائل الامنيه والاقتصاديه اولويه على
الكثير من القضايا القيميه او همم
السياسيه
بسبب ال- همم الازمه القائمه اليوم وهي
ازمه همم نظام عالمي هي ازمه صدام كبير
يدور في القاره الاوروبيه وهي طبعا ازمه
اقتصاديه ايضا قد تكون لها اثار وتداعيات
لفتره طويله من الزمن فاذا ارثر في دقيقه
يعني ما ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها
بريطانيا في هذا التوجه هل هي قادره على
التوفيق بين قيامها من حقوق انسان
والديمقراطيه وهذه الشركات
مقترحه مع دوليا
لا تحترم كثير حقوق الانسان وليس الدول
الديمقراطيه ولكن لا طالع لمكان اللي
بريطانيا مثل هذه العلاقات
من افريقيا واسيا التي ليست الديمقراطيه
وبالتالي هذا ليس بالتطور جديد المشكله
الرئيسيه البريطانيه هي علاقتها مع اوروبا
واذا لم تتغير حكومه
الاقتصاد البريطاني سيعاني سنوات طويله
قادمه شكرا لك
خبير في العلاقات الدوليه كنت معنا من
مدينه بريطانيا
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس كان معنا من
باريس
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]